je m'appelle si je le voulais je suis
grave
sa peinture est sensible au département
soit sensible la commission de faire ce
qu'on décide département de contre les
travaux réalisés par les différents
dictionnaires de sensibiliser les gens
du public puisque personnes âgées comme
scolaire bon déjà un planning à
l'inspecteur ou 1 par action l'année
dernière sur 17
hoeness le moindre set et laisse donc
c'est le matin aux points 4 4
c'est denis et direction ainsi six yeux
de man fleurier on vient on arrive on
garde les cages ici si la société
propres s'il n'y a pas de braconnage il
n'y a pas de date du vandalisme et si
c'est le cas on fait un compte rendu et
des fois on peut tomber comme les gardes
assermentés le roi de notre contrôle
on peut tomber je devrais poignets aussi
et là on peut faire un procès d'abba
l'aménagement des espaces naturels c'est
une de tes émotions aussi alors ça peut
être quoi par exemple les fascine dans
des travaux le nettoyage du site
ils ont fait les fascine après des
escaliers les mardis ce qu'a dit refais
al emarat d'escalier il est souffrant
je passais dans la nature vous êtes
passé une heure tu vois pas ce que
c'est un métier comment c'est difficile
pour votre physique parce que la réunion
c'est que les sentiers après sa cession
n'est par nature on pourra pas faire ça
parce que je vais pouvoir prendre pour
connaître les alpes
il faut être passionné déjà si vous
n'êtes pas ce sera difficile pour
prendre c'est compliqué ce nombre on à
reconnaître à prendre ce procès
d'anciens faut transmettre à prouver aux
autres donc c'est pas pour ça
voilà cent mille hectares de forêt et
une école unique au monde donc il faut
les gens prennent conscience que si y'a
plus avant dans le monde entier à dire
plus a donc ma mission à moi c'est
protéger sa préserver et transmettre aux
autres savoirs
et